all right so
so whether an industry academia
non-profits or government organizations
all over the world are struggling to
keep up with the massive amounts of data
being collected from various field
instruments devices online services and
more
and in particular we lack effective
solutions for helping people
interactively explore massive data sets
by interactive exploration i mean using
an an intuitive interface to make sense
of a data set for example to figure out
how to clean model and ultimately
extract insights from that data to make
decisions
now why aren't why are existing systems
unable
to support scalable interactive
exploration
on the one hand we have visualization
systems which can produce intuitive
image representations of data that
analysts can interact with and and as a
result can be engaging tools for data
exploration however these systems are
not scalable due to problematic
assumptions being made about the data
that's visualized so either that data is
small
say small enough to fit in main memory
on your laptop
or if it's not small enough the user has
to go process that data somewhere else
first
on the other hand we have database
management systems
where they're known for being scalable
efficient systems for data processing
and examples include money db defd sql
server and so on
the problem with database management
systems is that they're optimized for
executing jobs and data centers not
necessarily in terms of
interactivity or responsiveness to user
interactions with an interface nor in
the design of the interface itself
and this snapshot from the moneydb
website kind of sums up the experience
analysts often have with these kinds of
systems which in case you can't tell can
be kind of painful
so to scale up exploratory visual
analysis to support massive datasets
researchers and developers are
interested in integrating database
management systems with visualization
systems so the database management
systems can focus on what they're good
at efficient processing of complex
computation
and the visualization systems can focus
on what they're good at enabling
analysts to interpret and manipulate the
results of that computation in an
intuitive way
and i call the combination of these two
systems interactive data analysis
systems
so in this context performance now is
not defined purely by query speed
throughput and so on instead performance
is defined by how assistance behavior
helps or hinders an analyst's ability to
extract reliable insights from her data
so user behavior drives system
performance and system behavior drives
user performance
to further clarify the challenges in
designing interactive analysis systems
i'll talk about one specific example of
exploring satellite sensor data from the
moderate resolution spectroradiometer
of the nasa modus
so with nasal lotus data you can support
a wide variety of use cases say
measuring vegetation density tracking
hurricanes tracking phytoplankton
populations in the oceans
measuring snowmelt or snow cover over
time that's a particular scenario that i
studied in my phd
but the problem with the data from modis
is that it's large complicated and
difficult to manage
so it's multi-dimensional so here's a
tiny slice of nasa modus dia that i'm
showing you here it's multi-dimensional
it has a latitude longitude and temporal
information
modis also records many many different
wavelengths of light each referred to as
a modus band for example shortwave
infrared light
or band b6 or visible green light like
band 54
and on top of this
on top of this
two weeks of nasa modis data
uncompressed takes up about 10 terabytes
of space at least when i was working
with it before
so imagine being an earth scientist
wanting to do a time series analysis
over a long time scale that would be
quite challenging
so how do we bridge this gap between
large complicated moses modis data
and the
engaging and intuitive visualizations
that i showed you from before
well
hailing from the database research
community i might argue okay
a starting point could be to take the
data where here we're focused on a snow
cover so to take modis data and store it
in database management system so now we
can capture the snow cover computation
we're interested in as a sql query and
here we see a stylized version of a sql
query calculating a normalized different
snow index where we're taking two modus
bands b4 and b6 and calculating the
normalized difference between them
so now if we want to visualize our snow
cover results we could take this dbms
and connect it to a visualization system
we're here we're rendering the results
as a geographic heat map where regions
that are more likely to contain snow
are colored with a darker shade of blue
so the problem with this classic setup
is that database management systems
aren't designed to be interactive
resulting in an impedance mismatch
between that that system and the
visualization system
and this could lead to confusing or even
biasing the behavior of analysts as
they're exploring their data due to lag
or other side effects that they perceive
through the interface
but the problem of supporting
interactivity at scale can become
tractable through two key insights that
i study
so the first is not any old sql query is
going to be executed on database
management system the user interface
actually constrains the scope of queries
that can be executed
on top of this as users interact with
these interfaces they often do so in
predictable ways for example by zooming
in multiple times in a row
using these insights i develop what i
call behavior driven optimizations
where what i do is i analyze how people
explore data using visualization systems
i collect that interaction data and
build computational models to represent
the patterns of behavior that i observe
and i leverage these models in two ways
so first
i deploy optimizations that can take
advantage of these
knowledge of these patterns for example
if a user can if i have a sense of where
a user will explore in a snow-covered
dataset
i can preemptively execute those
corresponding queries and fetch the data
ahead of time to improve the overall
perceived responsiveness of the system
i can also take these models of behavior
and generate workloads that i can use to
evaluate other analysis systems
basically creating benchmarks
more broadly the question that drives my
research is how can we design adaptive
systems to amplify the strengths and
mitigate the weaknesses of both system
and human analysts
to answer this question i conduct
research along three main axis so
characterizing exploration or
investigating the different ways that
analysts explore data through various
visualization interfaces optimizing
exploration so designing new systems and
techniques to better support analysts
and benchmarking exploration we're
designing new methods for systematic and
repeatable evaluation of interactive
analysis systems
for sake of time i won't go into every
single project i've done along these
three nazis but what i will focus on in
the remainder of this talk
is how i study the impact of system
latency on user exploration performance
how i developed the forecast system to
address the performance challenges that
i observed
and how i extended what i learned from
forecast and other projects into a
performance benchmark that connects
insights from the visualization database
community base and i'll finish with some
of my ongoing work on optimizing and
benchmarking for interactive data
exploration
so first
although system latency sounds like it
could certainly be an annoying thing
it's not obvious how it actually impacts
an analyst exploration performance so i
conducted a series of amazon mechanical
turk experiments to investigate this
relationship between latency and user
exploration performance and i'll talk a
bit about what my results tell us in
terms of designing more effective
interactive data analysis systems
where here the context the context of
exploration is navigating large tiled
visualizations
so the system that i developed for cache
and then similar interfaces like google
maps take these large visualizations and
break them down into smaller pieces
basically tiles and what i'm interested
in understanding is what users do when
there's a delay in when those tiles
actually appear on the screen and i had
two particular research questions that i
wanted to investigate through this this
series of experiments
so first is how do people change their
exploration behavior in response to
latency
now the second question is how much
latency is too much for example is there
a magical latency threshold where
latency suddenly starts to become a
problem in terms of affecting users
exploration behaviors
this would be really helpful for say the
database community which is often geared
towards optimizing systems to provide a
better overall user experience
experience
for sure definitely in reducing latency
however knowledge of the users the
user's knowledge of the underlying data
set can also influence their exploration
patterns latency is not the only factor
so i'll talk about how i control for
both of these effects in my experiment
design
so the first
is to control for how much information
someone knows about the visualization
they're exploring so to do this what i
did was i abstracted the scenario i
showed you before so instead of looking
at specific kinds of tiles these new
cover tiles now participants in the
study would look at general image tiles
and they would look for a particular
target image mimicking an analyst's
interest in searching for something
interesting in the data
so with this setup now i can simulate
variations in user knowledge
and i broke this down into three
different levels that participants could
fall into
starting with being a data novice or
knowing nothing about the target image
being searched for up to being a data
expert where participants knew about a
couple different paths they could take
to explore the visualization to find the
target image
so now i'll talk about how i inject
latency into this interface to see how
these exploration patterns might change
as latency increases and i'll
demonstrate with an example so let's say
this large box here represents the
current visualization and the user's
current location in the visualization is
in the bottom left-hand corner what i
what i do is i insert two different
target images that the user could
potentially find
and i call them the low and high latency
targets because let's say the user moves
towards the latency target so the tiles
that this user will see
will appear faster or with low latency
but if they move towards the high
latency target then the tiles they see
will appear slower or with higher
latency
now i can address this first question of
how latency affects exploration patterns
for example if there's no latency or
latency has no effect on user behavior
then we would expect that participants
in this study would find these targets
with about equal probability but if we
see a consistent preference for say the
low latency target or the highland z
target that would suggest that latency
biases people's behaviors in terms of
how they choose to explore the
visualization
and i can actually uh model this as
shifts in target preferences as latency
increases
so here we have a
spectrum depicted along the y-axis
representing
target preferences so let's say
there's no preference for target
regardless of latency
then we would plot a point at the center
of the spectrum
if say there's a consistent strong
preference for the low latency target so
finding that target first as you explore
then we would plot a point at the top of
the spectrum
now what we can do is add an x axis here
showing what happens as we increase the
latency
that people see in the interface
so if
there's no effect of latency then we
would assume that there should also be
no shift in target preferences
but if there is a magical threshold at
which latency starts to become a problem
what we might expect is something like
an s curve where the inflection point of
this s-curve represents the threshold
that we're interested in for example
maybe one second or 500 milliseconds as
mentioned in the literature
what i actually found when i ran my
experiments
was something more like this a more
gradual almost linear shift
from having no
target preference to having a stronger
preference for the low latency target so
suggesting there's this gradual increase
in exploration bias as latency increases
and i found that whether participants
were categorized as data analysis or
data experts there was no significant
difference in the outcome
so what does this mean for interactive
data analysis systems well
unfortunately for the database community
i did not find an obvious single
interactivity threshold that we could
use for optimization instead i found
this
consistent relationship between increase
in latency and an increase in
exploration bias
where
the more people the more latency there
was the more people seem to bias their
expiration behaviors to avoid that
latency so whether you're reducing 10
seconds of latency or one second of
latency it just seems like it's always a
good idea to reduce system latency
so to summarize i conducted a series of
amazon mechanical turk experiments to
investigate this relationship between
system latency and user exploration
performance i did not find an obvious
latency threshold and instead i found
that
a reduction in latency in general can
help to reduce user exploration bias
so now i'll talk about a specific system
that i developed called forecast to
address this problem of system latency
so forecast is designed to reduce system
latency while users explore array data
such as the nasa satellite sensor data
and the key idea behind forecast is that
if we can understand how users tend to
explore their data then we can design
systems level optimizations to match
these known exploration patterns and to
do this i translated existing theory and
human computer interaction visualization
into code by training machine learning
models labeled with user interact with
labeled user interaction data
and what forecast does is it uses these
trained models to drive tile prefetching
optimizations so now i'll talk about how
i compute zoom levels and tiles in
forecast
so everything in forecast whether it's a
data set or a query is represented as an
array shown here as a grid so what i do
to compute zoom levels is i aggregate
every n cells of these arrays along each
dimension where i use a larger n to
calculate a coarser grains and level and
a smaller end to calculate a finer
grains and level
and then each zoom level can be
partitioned into fixed width blocks or
tiles
so forecast can compute tiles directly
and incrementally it doesn't have to
compute holes in level first but i won't
talk about the tile optimizations today
i'm just going to focus on the
prefetching optimizations that forecast
has
so now let me talk a little bit about
the forecast architecture so it has
three components the first is a
visualization front-end which is
responsible for managing the
visualizations that people can actually
interact with
then there's a server-side optimization
middleware layer which has two
components the first is a prediction
framework which takes interaction data
from the front end and uses that to make
predictions about where the user will
explore next in the data set
and then there's a separate tile builder
component which then translates these
predictions into queries for tiles that
actually get fetched from a backend
database management system
and here we use the array-based database
management system site b given its
native support for array-based
processing and optimization
so forecast also does interaction
interaction aware caching along every
level of this architecture but i won't
talk about those optimization
optimizations today again i'm focusing
on the prefetching optimizations
so first i'm going to talk about how
forecast predicts users exploration
goals which connects to where they're
going to explore in a data set providing
us an intuition for where and how they
might end up fetching tiles
or requesting tiles
so in particular the first core
contribution of four cache is the
translation of visualization theory into
a model executable by software
where i translate this theory into
specific goals users have as they're
exploring their data
or i call them analysis spaces so
foraging sense making and navigation and
the forging and sense making phases are
actually
derived from the parolee and cards sense
making model
and the proline card model has two major
loops of interest here so the first is
the forging loop
where what people do is they collect
potentially relevant and interesting
pieces of information for example in for
cash that might look like identifying
regions of interest to
investigate further
then the other main loop in the parolee
card model that we're interested in is
the sense making loop so in this case
the user takes the pieces of information
that they've collected and investigates
them in more detail to answer ascertain
potential relationships between them so
in forecast this might look like
investigating particular regions of
interest in more detail
so the thing about the purlin card model
is that's not able to capture
interactions for maneuvering between
these two clips for example zooming in
so i introduce a separate navigation
phase to capture this missing process so
now i'll demonstrate how i actually
apply these phases of exploration
through an example
so let's say we're exploring snow cover
again but regions that are more likely
to contain snow go from blue to red
so usually when we're exploring we start
at a coarser grain zoom level so we can
find things that we're interested in
so this represents the foraging phase
and let's say we come across this
mountain range here and we want to
export
so now we switch to the navigation phase
so we can see this mountain range in
more detail so once we've reached an
appropriate level of detail that we're
happy with then we'll start moving
around and investigating this mountain
range and these boxes represent the
tiles that get fetched along the way
now how do we actually use these
analysis phases to predict what tiles to
fetch next
oops
sorry
before we get there
people very rarely explore just one
region of interest right so let's say we
want to explore more than just this one
round range
what we're going to do is we're going to
zoom out again eventually and then we're
going to return to the forging phase to
find something interesting that is not
the mountain range we just saw so for
example let's say this cluster of red
pixels in the bottom right hand corner
all right now how do we use this
information
so for cache has multiple prediction
levels
now let's say
considering our previous example these
are just performed by pending
interaction this information plus the
user's current location gets passed to
this multi-level prediction framework
that forecast has where the top level is
the phase predictor
so we pass this pounding information to
the phase predictor and the role of this
layer
of the framework is to just say what
analysis phases these are currently in
let's say given all of the information
that we have the user is probably in the
sense making place
then this information gets passed to a
model manager which is in charge of
running multiple recommendation models
and you can think of a recommendation
model
as basically a predictor of a specific
low-level pattern of interaction where
some patterns might be more prominent
than others in certain analysis phases
so let's say in this case model two is
better at predicting tiles to prefetch
compared to model one for the sense
making phase so then the model manager
will use this information to allocate
space across these recommendation models
to decide which prefetch next
so then we run the models we get their
predictions we consolidate them and then
we send them to our tile builder
component for retrieval
so now i'll talk about two specific
recommendation models that build for
cache but i do want to mention you can
have however many models you want in
this design it's not limited to two
all right so the first model that i
built for for cache was is what i call
the action based recommendation model
and the idea is that the user
consistently moves in predictable
directions which we can capture with
simple markov models say mark off change
so we're going to revisit this nokia for
example but limit the movement to the
cardinal directions just for simplicity
so let's say we're exploring snow cover
and we're pounding right and then we pin
down and we pan right and then we pan
down intuitively we see this as
exploring diagonally along this
coastline to look at this snow cover
so though a markov chain might not be
sophisticated enough to capture all
these details it can capture this
diagonal padding pattern and extend it
to say predict that these will continue
to pan right and down
but you could say okay rather than
fixating on the specific interactions
that are being performed what if we just
look at the tiles that are fetched as a
result of these interactions and then
assume the user wants to see more of the
same thing well that is actually how the
signature based recommendation model
works
so and the idea is the user just wants
to continuously to see more of what
they've been looking at in the past so
let's revisit this example
and let's say we're panning down two
times in a row
if we were thinking of the action based
recommendation model what it would do is
continue to predict that these will pin
down but this is wrong so
this is not my area of expertise per se
but i'm pretty sure you're not going to
find a ton of snow
in that part of the pacific ocean
so what would the signature-based
recommendation model do
well
these boxes represent the tiles for the
user's current location and then
neighboring tiles
these tiles look similar to what the
user's been exploring in the past so
maybe what this model would do is
predict that the user would pan right or
maybe up back the way they came
so to calculate this similarity across
tiles i compute
signatures what i call signatures and
they're basically heuristics
so for example you could calculate a
histogram or a particular attribute in
each tile to estimate similarity you
could apply computer vision techniques
to the tiles to estimate similarity by
comparing the features that were
extracted and i'll talk about one
particular example that i used
so specifically sift i used the scalar
variant feature transform
and i extracted it from each tile that
forecast could fetch and the idea is
that because sift is a computer vision
technique that helps you
identify similar objects across
multiple images so what it does is it
extracts key points and you can think of
them as like landmarks or unique markers
for identifying the same object across
images the idea behind it is that if i
can do that i can potentially find
visual artifacts that appear
across multiple zoom levels so when
you're zooming in you're probably still
seeing the same thing it's just a little
bigger a little smaller
so to compute sift
what i did was i extracted key points
from each tile i clustered the key
points then i went back through the
tiles identifying which cluster the
frequency with which each cluster
appeared so then i'd end up with these
different histograms and then i could
use the histograms to compare similarity
between the tiles
all right so now how do i actually
evaluate this framework that i developed
for cache
well what i did was i conducted a a user
study with 18 earth science researchers
recruited from uw and uc santa clara
and the participants explored snow cover
visualizations exactly like the ones
you've been seeing throughout this talk
to explore nasa satellite sensor data
so given that latency can bias users
exploration behaviors i had participants
explore an idyllic version of forecast
where everything was pre-computed
and then instead i ran retrospective
performance experiments using the
resulting interaction logs
so to run these experiments what i did
is i just replayed the logs from that
study
i had an out of the box version of side
eb i didn't do anything fancy as far as
the back end and i compared with a
non-prefetching baseline to make sure
that refreshing is just generally a good
idea and then i compared with two
existing prefetching techniques at the
time
so one is momentum where the idea is
whatever the user did last they'll do it
again so if these are panned down they
would pan down again
the other technique that i compared with
is hot spot so if we do have access to
user's interaction histories we could
calculate in the data set the most
popular regions within that data set and
then assume that if the user is moving
towards one they will continue to move
towards one of those
popular regions or hotspots
in the absence of information for
example if the user is not close to any
known hotspots then the hotspot
technique defaults to momentum behavior
so my results show that forecast
provides
20 percent higher accuracy and 88 faster
response times compared to existing
techniques
where a correct prediction resulted in
negligible latency and a misprediction
resulted in queries having to be issued
this idb causing a significant
significant delay in when the user would
actually see the results visualized on
the screen
so here we have a line chart where on
the x-axis we have the number of tiles
that could be prefetched before each
user interaction
and on the y-axis we have the average
response time of the system in
milliseconds and we see that four cache
which is the orange line is
significantly lower than the other two
lines
so to summarize
i presented for cache a system for
visually exploring large arrays like
nasa satellite sensor data
and the key idea behind for cache is
that it leverages both theoretical and
computational models of user exploration
behavior to direct systems level
optimizations in a more intelligent way
so to evaluate forecasting conducted a
study with 18 earth science researchers
and find that forecast is 88 faster
compared to existing techniques
and as a result forecast can help to
reduce exploration bias as observed
through my study of how system latency
impacts user exploration performance
so now we'll talk about how forecast
sparked my interest in improving the way
we evaluate interactive analysis systems
as a whole
so if you're exploring nasa solid sensor
data or other large arrays it's clear
that forecast can provide some benefits
but if you're an analyst or another
researcher you're not just interested in
will forecast help me or not your answer
asks you're interested in this broader
question of well with the grand
landscape of interactive analysis
systems out there which one should i be
using for my use case or which system
should i be keeping my eye on if i want
to build a better one
and i realized it's actually not so easy
to try to answer this question so what i
tried to do at first is say okay well i
have evaluation data why don't i just
look at the evaluation data reported or
shared from for all of these other
systems and then see what i find
well
for some systems say wisdom mns and so
on they were also evaluated in a similar
way to forecast but they used completely
different input data sets they asked
people to explore that data in different
ways so they had separate analysis tasks
from what i used for my study
and i just couldn't make a direct
comparison between the numbers that they
reported and the numbers that i reported
on top of this there are other systems
where they were evaluated in terms of
performance but not through a user study
so then there's even less data that i
had available to me to try to make this
comparison even for systems that are
arguably more relevant for example
pirates
so in general with the way we evaluate
the systems right now there's just so
much variability that we can't really
answer that question this question
so a common and popular way to reduce
variability in the way systems get
evaluated is by introducing benchmarks
so i would be lying to you if i tried to
say there are no benchmarks in the
database visualization communities
because there absolutely are but the key
question here is are they applicable for
evaluating interactive analysis systems
and i would argue that they are not and
i'll give some examples so tpch is a
very well known and popular benchmark in
the database community for evaluating
database management systems for their
analytics support the thing with tbch is
that it's really good at simulating a
data warehouse but it's not good at
simulating the ad hoc interactions of an
individual analyst interacting with a
visualization interface
on the other hand we have benchmarks
like the visual analytics benchmark
repository in the visualization
community which act as a very useful
data archive recording how we've
designed different visualization
interfaces in the past for different
scenarios and different kinds of data
sets
but it's not a runnable benchmark like
tpch is tpch generates queries that can
be executed on database management
system the va vr is literally just an
unlinked archive
so here's my vision for what an ideal
benchmark might look like it has three
components starting with a data set
generator and what's nice about this is
that you would be able to generate a
data set with certain characteristic
characteristics you're interested in for
example certain data sets queue or data
set size and you could load that one
data set and do all the systems that you
want to compare
and that gives us a nice starting point
for an equal comparison
or an equivalent comparison
then we could have a workload generator
which then would drive consistent inputs
across these different systems
leading to queries that we could measure
to test their performance
and then finally we would want a
consistent set of evaluation metric
metrics to test those systems for
example the average response time metric
that i used to evaluate for cash
so as a first step towards achieving
this vision i led a large
interdisciplinary effort in building the
first dbms performance benchmark to test
real-time interactive visual exploration
scenarios
and the main contributions of this work
were the findings of a user study for
collecting relevant interaction data for
this use case
translation of that interaction data to
a benchmark that could actually be run
on database management systems and then
the findings of running that benchmark
with five existing systems showing that
none of the systems we tested actually
provides satisfactory performance for
real-time exploration even for what the
database community would consider modest
data set sizes of one to a hundred
million rows
so for a database benchmark to be
compelling
especially in this space we actually
need the community to be excited about
the use cases behind the benchmark and i
would argue not just for the database
community but the visualization
community as well
so i'll discuss a little bit about the
scenario we picked to anchor the
benchmark
and specifically we chose crossfilter
real-time filtering of dashboards via
brush filters or overlaid sliders and
i'll show an example here so here we're
exploring faa on-time flight performance
data through this dashboard built using
the falcon system from uw
and in this dashboard we have six
histograms that a user can interact with
and they're all connected so if the user
say manipulates this brush filter here
on departure delay in minutes all of the
other histograms update in response to
the user's interactions in real time
similarly if we create a new brush on
top of
distance in miles all of the other
histograms also update in response to
the user's interactions with near
immediate um
feedback
so because of the real-time nature of
cross-filter it's one of them arguably
one of the most demanding scenarios for
data exploration so if database systems
can support this they can support just
about anything but on top of this
because we need results to appear near
immediate we need to have some kind of
way of tracking this when we run our
benchmark so what we did was we adopted
an order of magnitude threshold of 100
milliseconds
from the literature
now how do we go from this use case to
an actual benchmark what we did was we
conducted a user study to better
understand how people actually use these
kinds of interfaces
and we had two specific questions we
wanted to answer so for the first was
what if any patterns do we see and how
users interact with these interfaces for
example do they actually leverage the
real-time nature of them
and then the second was how do these
how might these patterns affect the
benchmark so what kind of workload can
we expect and how does that influence
how we would design database management
systems in the future
in terms of study design we had 22
participants explore crossfilter
interface interfaces built using falcon
and they explored two out of three data
sets so movies data flights data and
weather data and then on top of this
they explored the data and completed
various tasks that we gave them
and here's an example of some of those
tasks
so now let me just give you a brief
overview of the study findings so one
major takeaway from the study was that
crossfilter encourages continuous
interactions
so here we have a bar chart showing the
different kinds of interactions that
participants could perform during that
study and we found that dragging of
brushes what i showed you in the video
was actually twice as popular as any of
the other interaction types so given the
opportunity it seems that people will
take advantage of these kind of
real-time interactions that provide
uh immediate near immediate feedback
second we find that crossfilter
encourages rapid interactions so more
interactions and less time downtime in
between interactions so here we have a
box plot
a series of spots showing the
distribution of interactions performed
on the x-axis broken down by the data
set that was explored and the complexity
of the task on the y-axis and we see
here that more complex tasks tended to
lead to more interactions being
performed
finally we find that crossfilter leads
to high query generation rates so not
only is dragging of brush filters the
most popular interaction type you also
find that it generates the most queries
on average 174 queries per second per
visualization
and the kicker here
is that there's not just one
visualization and a cross filter
interface right so with the example i
showed you before for any one histogram
that gets manipulated
five other ones have to update response
so we actually have to take that number
174 and multiply it by five to get the
true query rate over time
which would push this much closer to a
thousand queries a second
definitely over 900 queries a second
now so how do we actually take our user
study data and turn it into a benchmark
well first what we did was we took all
of the individual log records from our
study we mapped them to equivalent sql
queries using the ide bench framework
then to see how well database management
systems perform for different data set
sizes we created three different sizes
of data sets
from our user study data sets 1 million
10 million and 100 million words
to demonstrate the value of this
benchmark that we created we tested it
on five different systems
selected for their popularity and or
support for analytics
so for sake of time i'm only going to
highlight one result here
which is in terms of response rates so
for a cross ulcer interface to be
successful we need the query results uh
we need the system to be able to respond
to user interactions within 100
milliseconds with high rates of success
and this is admittedly a very modest
threshold
so what a database management system has
to do is return query results within 100
milliseconds or less with high rates of
success
and we measured this by calculating
response rate the response rate is the
percentage of queries that were
successfully executed within 100
milliseconds
and here we see
a grid of bar charts showing the results
so
in the 1 million rows case so the
smallest data set case
we see that two systems performed pretty
well moneydb and duct tape productdb is
definitely the best performing system
and this is interesting because duct
tape and money db are the systems that
are most geared towards analytics
however
as we increase the data set size from 1
million to 100 million rows we see that
db's near perfect response rate drops
dramatically to at best a 29 response
rate meaning that 71 of the time those
queries were not executed on time where
they were dropped
and in general we find that the best
performing systems were still two to
four times too slow to support real-time
variant use cases like cross filter
so to summarize i led a large
interdisciplinary effort to build the
first dbms performance benchmark to
support real-time interactive
exploration by crossfilter interfaces so
our study shows that when given the
opportunity people will take advantage
of the real-time
uh properties of crossover interfaces
but
in making a benchmark out of the
interaction data we actually found that
existing systems just aren't fast enough
to provide satisfaction performance for
cross-filter even for modest asses sizes
of one two hundred million rows
so now i'll briefly discuss my broader
research agenda and highlight some
ongoing projects that i'm particularly
excited about and share my larger vision
for this work going forward so to
reiterate the question driving my work
is how can we design adaptive systems to
amplify the strengths and mitigate the
weaknesses of system and human analysts
to address this question i conduct
research along these three axes which
also guide my research
agenda for example to further
characterize exploration i plan to
formalize how existing performance
models relate to
each other from models of human
reasoning to models of interface
structure to database cost models
to further optimize exploration i plan
to design more intelligent and
interoperable systems
and to enable broader benchmarking of
exploration systems i plan to leverage
my work and user modeling to do
dynamically derive
benchmarks directly from experiment data
so as part of this research done though
my students and i are interested in
helping people build their own high
performance dashboards for the first
where the first step is to help people
build their own visualization interfaces
especially with languages that are
powerful and expressive like d3
the drawback
a drawback though is that d3 can be
complicated and difficult to learn as a
steep learning curve if you will so as
an example here's a bar chart that was
discussed on stack overflow where the
bar chart itself seems very simple but
the code that the stack overflow user
had to write to generate said bar chart
was actually quite for books
so what i'm interested in is if we can
use automation to make it easier for
people to learn complex languages like
d3
so to the side my students and i have
built a system called myrni for
automated recommendation and
implementation of d3 visualizations
so the way mirani works is that you can
upload whatever data set you want in
json format and your knee will infer the
dataset schema and use that to
pre-populate some templates for
different visualization designs in d3
but the user can actually write whatever
they want they don't have to follow one
of those templates
but let's say we'll pick one here like
scatter plot
so the user can make whatever edits they
want say change the color scheme if
they're scatter plot your name will
update and show the results in real time
in parallel your name will also
recommend interactions that can be
integrated into your code so that
instead of producing just a static
visualization you can produce an
interactive one
so let's say here the user looks at the
recommendations and decides okay i would
like to include a brushing interaction
into my code so muni will automatically
add
the brushing interaction once the user
clicks on it
automatically add that directly into the
code and then the user can immediately
start brushing on their visualization
so to build mirini
we analyzed tons of examples from
blocks.org and observable including the
code and the output visualizations
we took the patterns that we observed
and we built them we used um
computational models to
learn these patterns
and then we also exploited
structural patterns in the code
to
to support our automated code
augmentation techniques
so analyze lots of examples trained
models to capture the patterns we
observed including patterns of code oops
externally
skipped ahead here
all right
but d3 is just one language and users
aren't going to use just a single
language there's actually a spectrum of
languages out there ranging from simple
languages like poly
um
or seaborn simpler not not dead simple
but simpler where
you sort of trade
simplicity for um expressiveness
easier to use fewer things you can do
with them and on the other end you have
things like d3 where the sky's the limit
but
it's more difficult to learn and i'm
interested in how users navigate along
the spectrum and how we can use
automation say in muni or even systems
like jupiter lab
to help users navigate this spectrum
smoothly going from less to more complex
languages and vice versa
but helping users build high performance
dashboards is not just about building
visualization interface it's also about
helping people test the interface and
make sure that it's fast enough
so one drawback of the benchmark that i
showed you is that
it's a specific dashboard design and we
derived a static performance test a
static workload to test the performance
but in reality if we want users to build
whatever um
dashboard they want this is not good
enough we need to provide users a way of
specifying what kind of dashboard they
want to test and then generate a
workload to support them
so for example if we could allow users
to specify their dashboards with a
declarative language
then we could use inputs from that
language
to create say a workload simulator
and then we can use existing models of
user interaction behavior and then
future models that we
that we would derive
to inform how to generate realistic
sequences of interactions on that
specified dashboard which we could then
translate into queries that get executed
on database management systems
on top of this
if we have a large data set that we
could use to infer how someone would
interact with the dashboard it might
also tell us how people would build
dashboards to begin with
so something i'm really excited about
that's um happened fairly recently is
that we're collaborating with tableau to
see if we can analyze analyze taboo
tableau public dashboards at scale so
that we can build models to
automatically generate specifications of
realistic dashboard designs as well as
build models of how users will interact
with said dashboards
so zooming out a bit these ongoing
projects hint at a larger vision i have
for my work which is that this idea that
people grow and change as they explore
and analyze their data and it would be
great for interactive analysis systems
to evolve with them
as users interact with systems like
forecasting unity
they're taking the insights that they
learn from their interactions and then
develop developing their knowledge and
their expertise so then the next time
they come to this these systems or even
other systems they're making more
informed decisions about how and why
they're going to perform these
interactions
so i'm interested in the long term
answering this question of how can we
design interactive analysis systems that
evolve with the user over time for
example throughout the course of one or
multiple data science projects
so with myrni we have we have a
technical report
it's still um basically under
preparation but we do have a technical
report on available on archive so if
you're interested you can check that out
yes that's that is my talk and i would
love to take questions excellent
thank you so much lelani we have plenty
of time for questions
um and if they come in over
zoom slack
uh will help us
with those
sounds good
so
can i just ask when out loud
but
she can hear me i guess
yes okay uh yeah i i thought the user
modeling was really cool um
and i was wondering like there's kind of
the assumption that like changing user
interface won't
um
change the behavior like when you're
like
like you have like the perfect no
latency or low latency condition
um
have you thought at all about how to
model like how changing the caching
would change the user's behavior
and how to evaluate that sort of more
complex scenario
this is a this is a great question
so
so actually the the first project that i
showed where i was running the amazon
mechanical turf studies the original um
idea that we were excited about with
that with that series of experiments was
could i mean this is not a
happy sunshiny way of asking this
question but
could we potentially manipulate users
into finding a particular target based
on the patterns of latency that they get
exposed to
so absolutely yes i think the system's
behavior that will have an effect on how
people choose to explore their data
um
and i i'm really interested in this
question too for visualization
recommendations because visualization
recommendations or even recommendations
on amazon right as you're buying things
they literally influence what you're
going to do just seeing them will affect
your behavior versus you know working
with a system
with an absence of recommendations so
what i'm interested in is a similar
question to you for recommendation
prevent systems which is
can you potentially
you know lead users down a path where
they would draw certain conclusions from
the data maybe in conclusions they
shouldn't be drawing
um through those recommendations and not
realize how much
um their exploration patterns are being
manipulated
this is again looking at it from more of
like a security perspective but i find
this very interesting
and this question of bias in general as
well
because systems can amplify bias biases
that are there
um and i'm definitely interested in
seeing how we can quantify that how we
can measure that and then what that
means for the systems that we build in
data science the the mirroring uh you
mentioned i think it's super interesting
and um and you talk about like the tool
will allow users to generate different
graphs like different kind of models
like so so i guess the templates are
like still limited like what if the user
want to build something that is not
supported like are there any features
that might for example draw opinions
from the experts or like any human loop
stuff
yeah so
the
the templates are really just a starting
point the work one component of miuni um
a user could actually write a d3
visualization from scratch and then mary
would still try to make recommendations
on interactions that you could add but i
agree the template strategy is limited
um the idea behind that is we
we wanted to pretty much mine templates
from a large corpus of d3 code that's
where the templates come from
and then on top of that we wanted to
make basically agile recommendations
where you can respond to what the user
is doing in the editor live rather than
relying solely on the templates
but the idea is that if um
if what the user's doing still looks
pretty similar to a template we've seen
in the past we could just try to fill in
the gap to
make a recommendation that will still
work in the code it's not perfect it
definitely still
can run into errors
we don't we don't have a panacea i'm not
pretending like i we have one of those
but
okay thank you
so i have a question um
so i i really love this idea of
capturing interaction traces and using
that to analyze
performance of the of the database
and the visualization
um
at the same time interaction traces are
fairly low
they're
level they're not uh
telling you a whole lot directly about
what the user is trying to do
and so
i wonder um
if you thought
at all about
you know what kind of information you
would like to get from the user if you
could ideally get it
as they're interacting with these
visualizations
could we go beyond the could we go
beyond the kind of low level
you know point-and-click
yeah i love this question so
um
in my more recent work i've been
thinking about interactions basically as
a mode of expression kind of like how we
might use words to express ourselves or
use other media to express ourselves
um and what we have in our heads is
never going to be represented perfectly
or at least not right now going to be
represented perfectly with that
particular mode of expression right
there's always going to be something
that gets translated and interaction
logs are
basically a translation reverse
engineering process
so um
i don't necessarily have
solutions yet but so
a recent
work that we
had a well hopefully we'll
most likely be at kai 2022 is we did a
wizard of oz style user study
where we basically um pretended to be
a
visualization design system and we
worked with experts in public health to
understand okay if you
as an expert had to recommend yourself
visualizations for some other colleague
to look at to get started on a new
project say analyzing um some national
health survey data
what visualizations would you as the
human recommend to this other human
and our interest was
you know in understanding what do people
value when they're creating
recommendations themselves like what do
they value in recommendations in general
and how does that align with or how does
that not align with the way we make
prioritizations in how we design
visualization recognition systems
so this is our way of trying to get at
you know what do people value what do
people care about
and are we you know are we aligned with
them
so trying to get get out of the kind of
log data format and think more about
um you know trying trying to find what's
what people are thinking
and then another thing that i'm working
on right now that are that my students
are working on is
in building a new performance benchmark
that rather than just taking the
interactions that other people performed
and saying
you know here's the best way to
benchmark just
how well would you support this thing
these people did rather than the thing
these people were trying to do
we want to simulate
um interaction behavior
and the idea is that if we can think of
specific kinds of goals like classes of
goals
that people might want to perform
and then we can create an approximation
of those goals for a new data set or a
new dashboard
then we could try to simulate someone
trying to achieve that goal using that
interface
basically that workload simulator
simulator work i mentioned towards the
end of my talk we are making first steps
towards that and what i like about that
is it's not just about you know oh yeah
this human in the past at some point
did this sequence of interactions if
your new system can do that sequence
interactions and you're good the idea
is trying to get away from that and
saying more
here's a set of goals we think users
often have here's how this goal might
manifest with your dashboard
and here and now we can test whether or
not your dashboard will allow people to
pursue that goal and if so what
interactions make the most sense in
trying to pursue that goal so now
it's at a higher level so we still need
interactions because they're a mode of
you know translation but now we're
translating from goals rather than just
using the interactions and not thinking
about you know
what they're connected to in terms of
what the user's trying to do right
and and just to follow up on that
how much do you think those goals
and the interactions that result
there there are two different levels
obviously but um how much do you think
the goals
differ depending on the data
right and the task so the tasks will
differ depending on the data but how
much difference will there be
i think there can be pretty significant
differences depending so let's say
one data set has temporal data
associated with it and another data set
does not that could completely change
the kinds of analyses that you're
available that how you have available to
you and then there for your goals yeah
i think i think it can have a huge
difference so
um we're starting small
we're kind of picking a core set of
goals that commonly appear and we're
sort of using we're relying on the
literature to help guide us there
and then the hope is that if we can
build you know a framework
that people can extend then as more
goals come in they can just
add and add them to that framework to
kind of capture more of the space
but it's a huge it's a huge space
there are a lot of goals someone could
have
all right um
well we're getting close to the end here
are any last questions
okay
great well thank you again lelani that
was a great talk and um
uh really glad that you could come down
for this
thank you so much this has been a ton of
fun i hope everyone has a great term
thank you
we'll see you next time